(chant)
- Il a entendu les histoires
d'horreur à Rome.
Au milieu des tombesncien
pensionnat Ermineskin,
le pape François a pu
se recueillir et surtout
du drame qui s'y est déroulé.
À Maskwacis, dans l'enceinte des
pow-wow, plus de 2000 survivants
accueillir le pape.
Avec cette immense banderole
portant le nom des disparus,
de rappeler au pape François
combien d'enfants ne sont jamais
revenus chez eux.
Le lieu était tout indiqué
pour prononcer les mots attendus
(applaudissements)
Des paroles spontanémentnémentnt
applaudies qui sont allées
droit au coeur.
le pape dénonce les effets
des politiques d'assimilation.
Il tend aussi la main
et veut Ses excuses ne sont
qu'un point de départ, dit-il.
D'autres gestes suivront,
promet le pape.
À Maskwacis, ses mots sont
accueillis comme u
ANDRÉ CARRIER, v.-p., région de
Winnipeg, Féd. métisse Manitoba
- Son excuse, pour
c'est une bonne fondation
pour notre futur vers l'Église.
mais qui devra absolument
être suivie d'acts
pour vraiment faire avancer
la récon
rappellent ces survivants.